[Music]
and babies everywhere news submitted by
JK has the best moms I agree that's very
true
I agree we'll see actually here I'm
still trying to figure out because I'm
trying for you oh you see what you do
because of new now I'm like I'm like how
do you tolerate it I mean but then that
must mean you're a great person
yeah yeah then also if you're a super
one wouldn't you want Superman not to
say you're not a super you know what I'm
just gonna do respect the fact that he
can still stick to his guns if you like
I think crazy [ __ ] but too bad that's me
I'm like I respected the Joker but I'm
the good guy
what hospital in Arizona is preparing
for a staff shortage after 60 nurses
became pregnant at the same time a
doctor [ __ ] em all no no they just it's
16 nurses feel like becoming pregnant
it's like really cool right now
especially being younger there's a good
boy yeah like the Kardashians did a lot
of yay cuz we need like a baby boom
right not here
oh we are overpopulated in Korea oh I
don't think people are gonna have as
many babies but like it'll be cooler to
have babies are like like you're near
younger xx the card if you had a baby at
25 Kylie Jenner no like I feel like the
older Kardashian's I mean it's different
for them too because they have money so
when you have money in your financially
stable you have a child whenever not so
true
at 18 yeah especially now because good
I'm saying like I was too young like if
I I mean I love my son and everything
but I was just like aren't you glad you
got it I have an aunt like that if you
do she got married a 1990 kid I like
yeah well aren't you glad you got it
done and then you're still like young
now and then like you got to experience
all this stuff with like now you're
older with the monies yes and no yes
because yeah it's awesome I had a kid
when I was 14 better question you just
asked a question
you're interrupting shut up
33:34 why is it about you now I've been
waiting for you to finish your story I
thought you guys were fighting so just
thank you Thanks we're not fighting I
don't even remember anyway the point of
this story here aren't you glad you had
Isaac young oh my god I'm trying to
remember to help you remember you don't
hear this okay fine I'll tell you why I
was but so I am glad because now Isaac
is 10 years old I'm 27
we're like BFFs because he's like
amazing so sweet he's like able to he's
funny like we're gonna have
conversations
he's almost wearing the same size shoes
as me like it so cool it's like I you
know I raised like my own little best
friend and that part is awesome [ __ ]
cute the part where I'm like man I wish
I would have been a little bit more
responsible is because I was way too
young I got foggy like I got [ __ ] for it
like everywhere I went with my son like
I got the worst looks I got like the
worst comments like they always looked
down on me for being a young mom but
he's understand the mexican communities
that part was hard but it was also
because I did I was not in a good place
in my life to bring a kid into the world
like I didn't I didn't show her my [ __ ]
out
it was hella irresponsible yeah and it
was just like ifile was in a better
place but against all odds though you
raised a [ __ ] good ass boy so that's
what matters the only reason why you got
looks was because you look like a
three-year-old said you look like a
child so they probably without your
makeup still look like a child
me and you at 17 or 18 we weird we look
completely different
yeah you look 17 now exactly but yeah so
yeah they're just good in bed but anyway
so this story here this takes place in
Arizona we said in the headline 16
nurses who work they all work in the
intensive care unit at this hospital
called banner desert Medical Center
they're all pregnant some of them did do
410 fertility treatments it's not
necessarily that they did it all on
purpose like they had some sort of pact
or anything it's just it was this all
one big-ass coincidence maybe they all
like just supported each other in my
they're all like different stages were
nice to each other and supportive and
then that chemical imbalance allowed
them to be more fertile you know yeah
support with each other and everybody
you know what girls periods think yeah
I'm saying it so it could be probably
the same thing with that song don't
don't ever all their kids get to be
friends together and hopefully they all
dominate like that first grade second
grade third grade together and they all
grow up to be nurses look kid yeah yeah
here's another photo they all got these
onesies that says like relax my mommy is
a banner nurse which is the name of a
what about that whatever - the hot
exactly so they've been planning for
months ever since they found out they've
been planning for the shortage again yes
so they're saying that all these nurses
are due between September and February
they'll they will go on and maternity
leave for 12 weeks yeah a lot of the
patients because they all started
showing or near the same time all the
patients are like what's in the water
pregnant yeah they were saying what's in
the water yeah calm heavily no this
there must be something in the water
lots and lots of [ __ ] the sperm big swap
there - with the walk where were you
were you in Arizona at any point during
that time and then you open water source
in Arizona at any time the only way you
could tie this to me is if there's
balloons okay oh do you ever like
worried that he doesn't like crazy Shane
you don't even know about that he's done
yes when we first dated we were first
dating he gets pulled over for running a
red light I'm like are what everybody
stop sign okay something that was red he
ran that and then he got pulled over the
cop goes you know they I don't know how
they do it back home but takes his ID
goes to his patrol car whatever it in
puts his information walks back close
sir you're gonna have to get out of the
vehicle and put your hands behind your
head and I was like who the [ __ ] am i
dating someone wonderful yeah so the
cops took him in Uncle Sam and I didn't
I didn't know why I had to spend the
night in jail
I'll ended up that use do you still not
know what no I know why I'm guessing it
was like my buddy had to go the same
thing and he was cuz like he had a
parking ticket something else something
very innocent like that yeah something
like two things that didn't add up and
he didn't pay off yeah it was just cuz
his dogs even pay his registration
[Music]
America is like scary when it comes to
justice and man we're not that harsh in
Canada like really did you see in
Toronto like somebody like ran over six
people in the cop didn't shoot him he
like talked him down and then arrested
him oh that's so nice in the state's you
would have just shot the guy for like
shoe first questions later where it was
in Canada the cops were like okay like
chill boba and he had hostage he had a
hostage with them and here's like shoot
me shoot me in the confidence you follow
the cops would have shot that
[ __ ] with the instance yeah and
then the talk them out of it any rest
Wow Oh to talk them out of it and still
shot him that's such an American Way of
[ __ ] yeah you're like I don't care I'm
Bob I shoot that [ __ ]
that's how it is and that's the law
where's the can that's like you know
what this guy's going to some [ __ ] and
let's like figure it out and we'll put
him in jail for it like let's
there's more to this that we don't know
way of thinking I think that's a great
way of thing I'm gonna hear some real
[ __ ] Nukem yeah goldurn [ __ ] new is
that what you think about Americans cuz
really accurate you guys know that
everybody else in every single country
around the world is looking at America
it'd be like what the [ __ ] is wrong with
these guys and then you guys are like
get out we're like that do you getting
so I'm getting a little bit call you
guys though you're like yeah you're like
that like you guys are [ __ ] crazy
people from other countries don't know
American criminals so here's the
difference I was in Toronto
I saw the gangs there should I saw no no
Toronto and I'll tell you right now like
the gangs are just this [ __ ] up well I
mean I saw some rumbles I mean I mean
everywhere criminals are criminals right
but there's the street gangsters and in
the fights in the level of things that
go on on the on what we witness it's
very mild compared to soar almost pretty
[ __ ] right we've got so many shootings
this summer right I mean I'm not trying
to have a dick measuring contest of like
who's the bigger criminal but what I
witnessed I was like oh wow
this is a lot more tame than what I'm
used to here because here is just it's
just on a different level like we just
have way more guns way more craziness
right so here's the thing here's the
difference because of that reason right
cops have to be hyper [ __ ] aggressive
maybe they don't have to but they're
scared because there's many many
instances where you pull someone over
and the first thing they do is just
start shooting at you that's what I'm
like why they should right away I'm like
the scissors there yeah yeah so just to
put it so maybe that's nothing to do
with race is what you're saying
what do you mean like like all these
like shootings that happen right away
oh no do they shoot everybody they
should got like this you blacks whites
everybody this is the media that that
shows statistically actually why you
know what I always thought that I can't
say that no but statistically white
people white people get killed the most
if you look at stats they get shot the
most by a pretty thick because you're
not basing it off of like you're being
real with your facts I'm not saying that
oh yeah yeah no that's that's completely
false and you're here's another thing
too we're right next to the border with
Mexico and the cartels are [ __ ] crazy
like they're on a next level of crime
nests like Americans look at their you
support the wall I don't know I don't
think the walls gonna stop anything no
but when Trump was like yeah there's bad
people coming in I'm like okay there's a
bad Jew from each community I could see
that no no I'm not even City their
shitty Indian people coming in and I'm
not talking about Mexicans though I'm
talking about cartels in particular
cartels are next level like it's just ok
so put put it put it into perspective
you're tourists in Mexico they'll stuff
your body with cocaine and send you back
to the states to get surgery so you get
cocaine out of your body and they don't
give a [ __ ] what happens to you it is
psychotic it is like a it is insane and
so I
a part-time police buddy out in Arizona
where they have a negotiation with the
cartels that they don't kill anybody in
the town and they just let them come
through and they'll cut they're coming
in with like droves of like thugs with
straight-up guns and they have to do it
this way or else they'll just start
massacring the people in the town so I
think what people don't realize is the
level of criminal activity that's
happening in the US and how militant the
police have to be interested in yet and
there's not enough police per square
footage oh that's a patrol there's a
huge like lack of police or something I
could see why like some cops were just
like shoo right away because they're
just it's like yo you're probably
terrified because America is just like
yeah man crazy do or act you or the
American thing again what do we like
[ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] yeah you [ __ ]
shoot it's like yeah like what it's
[ __ ] up dude
[Music]